The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And we've done some review.
Something else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, symmetry,
review principal axes ideas.
What else?
I think we spent
quite a bit of time
on generalized forces and
ways for computing them.
All right.
And I'm trying to begin
to summarize what we've
done up to this
point because we have
a quiz coming next Tuesday.
So some of yesterday's
lecture was
intended to kind of
start pulling together,
comparing direct versus
Lagrange, advantages,
disadvantages.
And on Tuesday next,
we'll do more examples.
OK, so the problem you're
going to work on today--
and you really are
going to work in groups.
And how many do we have here?
We've got four-- about enough
for three groups, let's say.
We have a double pendulum.
It's made out of two-- now
I have two pieces of chalk.
It's two slender rods, but
an approximation-- this
is a double pendulum.
They have many-- that one and
this one have a lot in common.
Takes how many coordinates to
completely describe the motion?
One for each rod, right?
And the coordinates up there
that are drawn in that diagram
is the angle of the first
one with the vertical
and the angle of the
second one with a vertical.
And with that,
you can completely
describe any allowable
motion of the system.
So a double pendulum
has a property
that it's got two natural
frequencies and two mode
shapes.
That's the shape
of the first mode.
Both masses go in
the same direction.
And the second mode
looks like that.
The two masses go in
opposite directions.
Not with equal amplitudes,
but opposite directions.
And it's a different
frequency too.
It's higher.
So it has two natural
frequencies, two mode shapes.
And if you had-- in
this case it shows
a force acting on the
system, pushing this thing
back and forth.
And we're interested in
the generalized forces,
or thinking in terms
of the work done
by the non-conservative forces.
So the exercise to do in
groups-- like four or five
of you are a group.
You five are a group.
And you two, four,
five are a group there.
Work this out.
Find this vector.
This is the position
vector to the point
of application of the force.
And we want you to do that.
Actually, I did
something last time,
and I'm almost
forgetting to do it.
I want to remind
you of something.
Professor Gossard, each
week for the recitations--
he teaches Thursday ones-- does
a write-up of the recitation.
And they're posted.
So this week the solution
to this problem is posted.
But also, a little quick
review of the important stuff.
So this would be posted.
And basically I've redrawn
it up here on the board.
So this is this kinematic
method for obtaining
generalized forces.
So a body with N forces on it.
Here is the ith one.
At each point of
application of the force,
there is a total
virtual displacement
that basically
comes from the sum
of all the individual
generalized
coordinate virtual motions.
You sum them up,
you get the total.
And so therefore, at the point
of application of each force,
there is a total amount of
virtual work that's done.
So the total
non-conservative work
is the sum of the
virtual work done
at the point of application
of every force summed over
all the forces.
And remember, inside of
here, the total displacement
at every location is a summation
over of all the generalized
coordinates.
So it really ends up as a
double sum, this dot product,
the forces times delta ri.
It's a double summation
over the forces
that are applied and over
the generalized coordinates.
But at the end of the day,
what you end up doing,
the calculation
you want to do, is
you need to know the generalized
force-- the force associated
with each generalized
coordinate.
And that's the summation
of the contribution
of the virtual work caused by
that coordinate's motion dotted
into the force at
every location.
So at every location,
there's a little contribution
to the total work done.
And therefore, the total
generalized force is this sum.
So today's problem is easy
in the sense that i is 1.
You only have to
deal with one force.
But this is a little
messier problem
in that in order to
do this, you need
to be able-- this is the
r sub i in this case.
Here's point P. I want you
to first, just in groups,
work out what this vector is,
rP, in the system as drawn.
Here's the inertial
system xy, generalized
coordinates theta 1, theta 2.
And this bar is L1 long,
and this bar is L2 long.
And come up with an answer in
a form like this, something
in the i hat direction
plus something in the j hat
direction.
And then as your group
finishes-- this is group
one here-- come
put your answer up.
Second group, put
your answer up.
Third group, put your answer up.
And we'll move on.
This will go pretty fast.
All right, looks
like everybody's
pretty much in agreement.
Not much to talk about.
So let's do the next piece.
So the next part is to
compute your variations,
this part of the calculation,
for each of the coordinates.
So do rP with respect to theta
1 and rP with respect to theta 2
and write down your answers.
So the last step here is
get q theta 1 q theta 2.
So move on to getting the
two generalized forces now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You could.
And then if you
did, then this would
have to be a summation
over two components.
Remember, this is a sum.
It just happens in
this example, we only
have i goes from 1 to 1.
But if there were two forces,
then you would do this twice.
You'd have an r1 with respect to
theta 1 and an r2 with respect
to theta 1.
And you'd do this product twice,
add the two pieces together,
to get the total-- the
total generalized force is
the sum of the bits
that come from all
of the individual forces.
AUDIENCE: So if [INAUDIBLE]
just doing theta 1,
but [INAUDIBLE] two forces,
you just do one force,
and then you do
[INAUDIBLE] force--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so now here let's
have a B. We'll call
it just B force.
And it has to Bx components
and By components.
You would now also have to
compute what would be rB.
You would find it.
Then you'd have rB would
be this vector, which
is just that piece
plus this piece, right?
So you'd have just those--
rB would be this plus this,
and then you would do
the derivative of rB
with respect to theta 1.
And you'd get something.
And derivative of rB
with respect to theta 2.
AUDIENCE: So then you'd just
do the rB equals [INAUDIBLE]
for one force, and then
you do the rPe [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you have two-- so
this thing would end up
being the summation of
two contributions, right?
This would look like an FB
dot rB with respect to--
and this is just for
just one of them.
So we'll do the theta 1.
With respect to
theta 1 plus F-- I'm
just calling this one F-- dot
derivative rP with respect
to theta 1.
So you get two contributions
from the two forces
give you the total q.
This would be q theta 1.
And then you'd do it
again for the theta 2.
And you'd have two
possible pieces.
AUDIENCE: So you try to find
r's for every force [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: At every point
of application of a force,
you define an r.
You eventually need to do this
summation for every force.
All right.
Everybody's got
the same answers.
So now I'm going
to try to-- this
is an indirect way of
answering your question.
I'm now going to try to
convince you that you're wrong.
And I want you to tell me
why my logic is flawed.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK?
So I look at these
answers here, and so this
says that if-- this line
right here, if I caused
a little delta theta 1
here, that swings this arm
through that amount.
And it moves a distance in the
x direction, L1 cosine theta
delta theta 1.
And it moves over that
little bit right here, right?
OK.
And you're telling me
that this point over here
moves that amount.
The point of application
of this force
due to delta x, delta theta
1, is this delta theta 1.
There's no L2 involved.
So to me, it seems like
here's this pendulum.
And if I move this first piece
by a little bit, delta theta 1,
this piece also moves.
And so if you just think
of a straight piece,
delta theta 1 times
L1 moves a little bit.
But down here it moves
like twice as much.
So I think that when you
move this little delta theta
one, that you ought to get
even more motion down here.
And yet your answers say
that that's not true.
Tell me why-- what's
flawed in my reasoning?
AUDIENCE: So when
you-- I'll try.
When you [INAUDIBLE]
theta 2, [INAUDIBLE].
And now when you
move by theta 1,
[INAUDIBLE] all points
move the same theta.
So even though [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying that
we argue that when
you have one virtual
displacement, or in this case
a rotation delta theta 1, we
freeze all other generalized
coordinates.
That means we freeze delta
theta 2 and don't let it change.
Delta theta 2 is measured with
respect to the vertical, right?
So if that moves
over delta theta 1,
this whole thing
would-- this angle here
we go from delta theta 2 to
delta theta 2 plus delta theta
1 if my argument's correct.
But for my argument
to be correct,
that would have to swing
by delta theta 1 over here
as well.
But the fact that we
freeze theta 2, in fact,
the angle between these
two things has to change.
This has to open
up a little bit.
So when this is
moving over, this
is dropping down so that
this point, this whole body
only translates.
So that whoever described
it as just pure translation
of the second body, that's
another way of saying it.
So you've got to
remember what it means,
freezing all the other
generalized coordinates
and only allowing the
one you picked to move.
Good.
All right.
Nice work.
We've got some time left.
So do you have any
questions from problem
sets, lectures, just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When
you're calculating
kinetic energy of
a rotating body,
there's an omega [INAUDIBLE].
In the homework,
the last homework,
I didn't know which
omega could take,
whether to take it from
the wheel or from the axis.
PROFESSOR: Oh, this is the
rotating thing with the--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK.
AUDIENCE: There's
two omegas there,
and I didn't know which
omega [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So should we just
talk about that problem?
Are other people-- this is the
one where you had basically
the rod, and on
the end of the rod
was the wheel,
which was rotating.
So this was going around at
some omega 1 in the z, right?
And this was
rotating, and I think
this was like z, maybe x and y.
So it was rotating about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it had a negative.
It was a negative [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, it was a-- yeah.
Actually, I think I have it here
with its correct definition.
So rather than try to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because there
was the positive [INAUDIBLE],
and then there's
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Here it is.
Let's get the picture right.
And there was an
x, a y, and a z.
And this was cap omega.
And this was omega 1.
And that's minus,
in minus direction,
for this system, right?
OK.
So then we're trying to
compute T for this system.
1/2, and what'd we call
for the masses here?
This was m1, and
this was m2, I guess.
Yeah.
So this T for 2-- T1 you don't
have a problem with, right?
T1 is just a shaft, just a rod.
It's pivoting about its
end 1/2i about-- if this
is-- I call it o.
1/2i, i with respect
to o, mL squared
over 3 times that squared.
You're done.
That's the energy of this part.
This is the
problematic one, right?
The piece of it.
So 1/2, I would say mass 2.
And this does have a point.
They called this point B here.
Velocity of B dot velocity of B.
So that's the 1/2mv
squared piece of it.
Plus 1/2 omega dot
h with respect to G
for-- this is mass 2.
So you have a contribution
to the kinetic energy
of this that comes from its
center of gravity translating,
and a contribution from the
rotor rotating with respect
to its center of
mass here, G here.
And that'd be the
expression you use.
And then the problem is, what
omega is the trick here, right?
OK.
This is the one that had the
concept question I talked
about in class
because it came up,
and I hadn't thought
about this, about the body
coordinates attached to this
are actually rotating with this.
And that gets messy
trying to figure out
what are the--
how do you break--
you're supposed to
express the angular
rotation in the
body coordinates.
But this angular
rotation, this one
actually is lined
up with this axis.
And you could have body
coordinates on here.
You could have a--
if this is a y,
you could have a body coordinate
x and z that rotate with it.
But this Component would just
be still along this axis, right?
So the concept
question [INAUDIBLE]
was basically, are these
body coordinates, x, y, z,
attached to the rod?
Principal axes for this body.
And the complication here is
that this body is rotating.
And so this x and this z
don't rotate with that body.
And so they're not body fixed
coordinates for that body.
But in fact, they're still
principal coordinates
for that body.
Why is that true?
AUDIENCE: Because
you have [INAUDIBLE].
And you can take whatever
you want for the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're close.
This body is axially symmetric.
And so at any
instant in time, you
could say that--
you could define
a principal coordinate
on this body that
is lined up with these.
So for axially symmetric
bodies, you could do that.
You can do that.
You can just say, at
an incident in time,
let's compute the
kinetic energy.
And we have the
rotation of that body
defined in the instantaneous
principal coordinates
of the body.
So now omega for
the second body is
this in the k minus omega 1
in the j of the x, y, z system
rotating with the rod.
And then to complete
this, what's H?
So H with respect to G
is Ixx Iyy Izz times--
and now this one's rotation is
0 minus omega 1 and cap omega.
And I multiply that times
this with the definition
that the first one gives
me the I, second one J.
And so I end up with two pieces.
The first one is zero.
I get an Iyy.
And remember, these are
defined with respect
to center of mass of the disk.
Iyy minus Iyy omega 1
j plus Izz cap omega k.
And that'd be the angular
momentum for the disk.
Right?
And then the kinetic
energy, the 1/2 omega dot H,
you now just have another omega
1/2, and you have a vector,
0 minus omega 1 J
cap omega k dotted
with the H vector, which
is your 0 Iyy omega 1
j and Izz cap omega k.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And if that one's
negative, then it'll
happily fix this
one because it ought
to come out looking like
omega squareds, right?
And so out of this, you get Iyy
omega 1 squared plus Izz cap
omega squared.
And that's the second piece,
and you add it to this piece.
AUDIENCE: So is there ever a
time where the omega's inside
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So let me-- we
have a total-- so let's just
talk-- we have H
with respect to G.
Or a slightly simpler example.
So H for this system with
respect to the center
is H with respect to
G plus rG with respect
to the center cross PG, right?
I can write the angular
momentum that way.
And first piece we know.
The second piece, rG, is in a
r hat direction, if you will.
The P is going
around the circle.
And so the cross
product of those two
gives me a component, what's
the direction of the result.
So this is r cross theta hat.
You get a k.
This ends up being-- this
gives you a k component.
And this one we write out.
So this is minus Iyy omega
1 j plus Izz cap omega k
plus some stuff that's in the k.
Agreed?
And I want to know the
torques required to make
this system do what it's doing.
How do I get the
torques required
to make the system go around?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Sum of the external
torques equals dH.
Now, with respect-- remember, we
would ordinarily usually write
that as an A. We'll call
it H with respect to O dt
plus velocity-- usually we
call it A-- with respect to O,
cross P. Right?
In this system,
what's the velocity
of this piece, this term?
Zero.
So we don't have
to worry about it.
So the sum of the
external torques
should just be the time
derivative of this angular
momentum vector.
Right?
And dH then O dt is equal to the
partial derivative with respect
to t of H. And I'll
write it like this.
This is in the rotating frame.
So this is the piece from
inside the frame plus,
this is just the derivative
of a rotating vector.
Omega cross H. And the issue
here is, what's the omega?
That's really what this
question comes down to.
When we did this
problem, we found
that H came from taking
the omega, the vector,
multiplying it by this, and
we got these two pieces.
And so it started off with
components in the j and k
direction, and it came out
with components in the j and k
because this was diagonal.
So we have principal axes.
We came out with
these two pieces.
So the angular momentum has a
j component and a k component.
What is actually--
now, this vector,
this angular momentum
vector, the reason
we have this second term
is because of the change
of direction of a vector.
This piece comes from taking
the time derivatives of the unit
vectors in the problem.
The time derivatives of the
other stuff in the problem
has been taken care of by this.
So this only deals with the
time derivatives of the unit
vectors.
So what is the
actual rotation rate
in this problem, the
rate at which things
are changing direction?
Which one's changing direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Is this one
changing direction?
No.
So actually, it doesn't give
you any derivative, right?
Is this one changing direction?
Yeah.
And at what rotation rate
is it changing direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Capital omega.
But why not-- but it's not
changing little omega, is it?
The math, the vectors
works that all out for you.
Because this is in the
j direction, and this
is the same.
You just use the same
total rotation vector here.
And this will have
in it the zero,
the omega minus omega 1
j, the plus cap omega k.
And the parts that
you don't care-- this
crossed with itself
goes to zero.
So even though you're just going
ahead and leaving this in here,
it doesn't result in anything
because the cross product
would-- cross product with
itself gives you nothing.
So the only piece that
actually contributes nonzero
contribution to this
answer is this crossed
with the pieces in here.
So when you're
taking derivatives
of rotating vectors, remember
the original formula.
And the original formula
is the derivative
of the vector in
the rotating frame--
is this magnitude
getting more or less--
plus just the
rotation rate crossed
with the original vector.
And the pieces that are
common just fall out.
The piece of this that is
due to its own rotation
doesn't enter into it.
This rotation doesn't
contribute to that d
by dt of the rotation.
Just works out for you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What would happen
if that just [INAUDIBLE]
rotates like this, but also
rotates on its own axis
as it does it?
PROFESSOR: You mean if
this one is going in the k?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
didn't have the big omega term
because the actual thing isn't--
the big omega would be taken
into account when looking at the
first term of kinetic energy.
PROFESSOR: If this one also
had some k rotation in addition
relative to here, we'll call
it omega 2 in the k direction,
then what's the total
rotation rate in the k
direction for the disk?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You add
cap omega, 2 omega 2,
and you'd have its total k
directed rotation, right?
And if you did that,
you'd end up in here
with an omega plus omega--
cap omega plus omega 2 k.
But when you came over to
do the time derivative,
you just leave all
those things in there.
And the ones that
you don't care about
will just cancel
out because they're
cross products with themselves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] omega
also appears [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
Well, the cap omega
appears in this piece.
But this goes to k.
We did a particular problem.
I'm not trying to
prove this in general,
although there's probably
a way to do that.
This problem, this term
is in the k direction.
And therefore, k hat does not
change direction with time.
Therefore, the dH dt of
this piece goes to zero.
So we only had to
deal with this part
in taking the time
derivative that dealt
with changes in direction.
It's only the
changes in direction
that the omega cross
something matters, right?
Good question.
Something else?
Recent problems.
Somebody in the last
class asked about,
had a question about this thing.
That bring anything to memory?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I see some grimaces.
What troubled you
about that problem?
What troubled the last group
about that problem was the
posted solution.
They didn't understand
the posted solution.
So I ran through-- I
showed why the posted
solution works the way it does.
AUDIENCE: Well, one
confusion that I
had had doing this problem was
that the spring for the wheel
mass, when that exerts
displacements, Newton's
third being what it
is, should it also
exert some force on
the large base mass
as well, so you should
take that into account
for the total displacemenet
caused by springs
for big mass, the big--
PROFESSOR: Are you talking
about not computing-- just
giving equations of motion, or
computing generalized forces,
or what's the context?
AUDIENCE: Yes, when
you're computing
your equations of
motion, you have
to take into account
from the larger
mass of the displacements
in the spring,
it's attached to the
wall, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: As well
as the-- yeah.
So if you're doing this
by the direct method,
you have to figure that out.
So here's a way of doing it.
This is a way that I think
the-- the way the student
just read off his paper.
So I said, let's talk about
the forces in the x direction
on the main mass.
Well, that's mass 1
times its acceleration
must be equal to all
the external forces.
This is minus kx minus bx dot.
This is minus the x
component of the spring force
minus the x component
of the friction
force from the wheel minus the
x component of any normal force
from the wheel.
And I do the same thing
for the second mass, M2.
The total forces on it
must be equal to its mass
times its acceleration.
Well, its acceleration
I'm doing this just
to get in the x direction.
Its acceleration in the x is
the main mass, x double dot,
which it's sitting on.
And the x component of
the relative coordinate
x1 double dot.
This is the total acceleration
in the x direction
of the second mass.
And the total forces
on that second mass
are-- signs are changed.
Internal force, internal
force, internal force,
plus the force that was applied.
Actually, here it
is written out.
Here is that external force
that was applied to that wheel.
If you take these two equations,
you just add them together.
All of the internal
forces drop out.
Plus fx minus fx.
All of those drop out.
And you end up with an
expression that says,
this is a system.
The total external forces on
the system in the x direction
must be equal to the
total mass of the system
times the acceleration
of its center of mass.
Right?
That's what Newton said.
Well, the acceleration
of the center of mass
is the sum of the
individual pieces
times their individual
accelerations.
The sum of the total mass
times the acceleration
of the center of mass
is equal to the sum
of the individual masses times
their individual accelerations.
Mass one, its acceleration.
Mass two, its acceleration
due to its local coordinate
plus its acceleration due to
the main mass acceleration.
And all of that's got to be
equal to the external forces,
which are now only minus kx,
minus bx dot, and plus F.
And this term here,
this stuff, all that,
including this, these
three M X double dot terms,
all added together
as the same thing
is the total mass times the
acceleration of the center
of mass, which is somewhere.
But that's a completely
legitimate equation
for this system.
And it involves both
masses, both coordinates.
So this one here would just
be some x1 double dot times
a cosine phi or a sine phi
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: So for this
problem, is there
only one equation of motion?
PROFESSOR: Oh no.
There still has to be two.
But I've just shown you a
way of getting at one of them
without ever solving
for the internal forces.
By just realizing that
if I separate them,
that Newton's third law,
all the internal ones
will cancel when I add
the two pieces together.
I still have to get
a second equation.
Where would you get it?
AUDIENCE: Sum of
the forces in x1?
AUDIENCE: They're
rotating [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
want to do something
where you don't have to
solve-- you don't want
to have to solve for any
of these internal forces
that you don't know, right?
So the spring force
you can know because it
is a minus k times the
coordinate that you
have to use, minus kx1.
So I would go in
here, and I'd say
maybe the-- what's the sum of
the torques about that point,
perhaps.
AUDIENCE: There's
no slip, right?
PROFESSOR: And no slip.
So these things--
that avoids having
to deal with any
of these forces.
The real force acting
on it, real force,
you have to deal with that.
And the minus kx1
force you need.
It comes into your
equation of motion.
If you do that
particular approach,
it has one problematic--
it's not terrible
but you have to remember
to deal with it--
is that the sum of the x torques
about that point we'll call A
is d HA dt plus
vAo cross P, right?
Or I gave you an
equation yesterday.
This is easier to
do usually if you
do d HG dt plus rG with
respect to A cross the mass
times the acceleration
of g with respect to o.
This would be the
second mass, M2.
You can derive.
It's about three lines.
You can prove that this
statement's the same as that.
This one, turns out
this one's less work.
And the reason that this one's
more work is this term always
cancels out.
Cancels out with a
piece of it is generated
when you do this calculation.
But you know how
messy this stuff gets.
You've got all these unit
vectors running around
and cosine thetas
and sine thetas.
It's a lot of work
to get this piece.
And it's twice the
work because you
have to go in and find the
piece that cancels it in here.
So if you actually-- I sat
down about a week ago and said,
there's got to be a way
to get rid of this thing.
And there is, and it
comes out like this.
Now there's no
pieces that cancel.
You cancelled out in the proof,
and get this piece to go away.
And you're left with this.
So this is the distance
from your point
to the center of mass.
In this case, it's just r.
And the only thing
you have to calculate
is the acceleration
of the center
of mass, which is capital X
double dot plus X1 double dot.
You know that.
So this is vastly easier to do.
AUDIENCE: So I understand
how to use that if I'm
using different [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Center of mass,
I didn't get the last bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's the other.
Because you're doing
it around point
A is what gets you
into this mess.
If you're doing it-- as soon
as you work with respect--
if you're working with
G, the center of mass,
then this is vG cross
vG, which is always zero.
This has a vG in it.
So that's the reason we like to
work around center of the mass,
but we don't do
centers of mass when
it causes us to have a whole
bunch of external things
we don't know.
Thanks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].